In lesson two,
we looked at different ways that IOS
apps present multiple pages of content.
We said that we'd return for
a deep dive into how side to
side navigation presentation works,
and here we are.
Using navigation controllers is
an absolutely fundamental skill.
We're also going to take one more step
with the iTable views and make and
app that responds when
a user taps a table row.
An essential interaction when
navigating a multi page app.
Let's look at a few examples
of side to side navigation.
Here in the settings app,
you can see that taping on a cell drills
down into the next layer of
the navigation hierarchy.
The settings app has multiple layers.
Let's say,
I want to change my Siri settings.
I tap General and then Siri, Language,
and then I can give Siri
an Australian accent.
I can always return to the previous
view with this Back button,
ultimately bringing me back
to the root view controller.
Notice how intuitive this flow is.
Users have come to expect this type of
movement through a layered structure.
If you take advantage of iOS UI
conventions in your app design.
Your users won't need to be told how
to find what they're looking for.
But let's check out the IOS music app.
If I go into the more tab it
brings up a table of options.
Then if I drill down into genres and
country, eventually.
I can bring up the songs from
my favorite show Nashville.
You can see how you table
views are in IOS apps.
This action button on the right takes me
to the song that's currently playing.
Once in the player, this action
button brings up a with album info.
Have a close look the nav bar.
The back button and
the title are standard.
They're always there.
The action button on
the right is optional, but
something you'll see frequently.
How does the app know where to go,
when the back button is pressed?
When we drill past a page of content,
where does it go?
In other words,
what kind of state is being managed
by this navigation controller?
We have to figure all of this out.